the government balanced the books
arriving back in Westminster and walking
into a crisis
the cabinet descends on Downing Street
hours after another emergency Bank of
England intervention huge spending cuts
needed now to balance the books and
restore the trust of the market
ministers debating where the acts will
fall will it be austerity by the back
door Simon Clark how can you help the
most vulnerable Chloe Smith if budgets
are tight 15 cuts to departments Mr
Buckland do you think the public sector
can wear that
MPS return to Parliament today desperate
for answers boring costs Rising interest
rates up Pension funds on the brink
faith in government shaken all since
they were last here the bank of England
now warning of a material risk to
financial stability a Chancellor Under
Fire it does not need to be this way so
will the chancellor now put aside his
pride do the right thing for our country
end this trickle-down nonsense and
reverse the budget
[Applause]
do they want to uh stop uh the basic
rate the card and the basic rate Tori
MP's fear having to justify any cuts to
their voters confirmed to this house
that uh the government will not balance
the forthcoming tax cuts on the back of
the poorest people in our country as we
make these decisions that my honorable
friend refers to of course we're gonna
balance uh considerations of fairness
fairness hard to achieve when spending
cuts could exceed 60 billion pounds a
year but it's that or another U-turn for
Liz truss either a huge screeching
revert about turn on tax so raising
taxes to fill this hole or some
remarkable uh levels of spending cuts if
he wants to balance the books off the
back of cuts in public spending a really
big return to those days of the early
2010s when we had severe austerity and
cuts across public spending given the
scale of spending cuts in the offing
that's months of the most difficult
decisions a government can make all
compressed into three weeks and
announced on October the 31st no wonder
their attention's all over Whitehall
about what to do be it on defense or
whether or not to keep the manifesto
migration cap and once the decisions are
made she then has to keep her party with
her
one Tory MP told Sky News the government
has the priorities wrong and should do
another U-turn well it may well be that
perhaps corporate taxation will have to
rise or stay at a level higher than the
chancellor would have liked an issue
that will bring money in and that will
be one thing that will be sensible this
is a matter of timing and I think that
it's clear that some of that needs to
wait
decisions here driven by bigger forces
than politics ministers hemdin by market
nerves and the cost of borrowing it's
not clear how much the people in
Parliament are in the driving seat Sam
coat Sky News Westminster